Angell David Blaine [ __ ] my name is
Gary Farrar I am a magician and a
Mentalist in New York City I have snuck
into the BuzzFeed offices pretending to
be a psych student who is administering
tests to some of the staff my name is
Gary okay I'm a psych student we're
gonna work on like a little evaluation
where we basically evaluate people's
perceptions and observation skills drunk
we're gonna give them some drinks and
see if they can still observe as well so
we're getting drunk
no taking tests and seeing if we pass or
fail those tests better or I function
better on alcohol okay you guys are
gonna drink for a little bit we'll come
back we'll see how you do what they
don't know is that I'm gonna be sneaking
in magic yes very good drunk led Frank
[Music]
obviously well toxicated at this point I
feel like I'm making like the ugly drunk
face right now if you can catch your
breath carry we're little people re but
can we drink really quick like yeah yeah
doctor let's go it oh man
so the first thing we're gonna do is
just like a reflex test I'm gonna ask
you a question don't respond keep your
mouth open so like if you had the
impulse your lips to move
but don't don't actually do and then the
idea is like as you get drunker
sometimes you can't control the impulse
to stop all right what is your wife's
name oh I can feel myself I didn't even
want to say it but like my mind was like
do some cuz I got like a it was like a
be like Brooke what yeah right what is
it Brigid regiment yeah okay what let's
move on to test-tube how much money
would you say is there one two three
cuatro Sinko how much value is that
that's the real question
it's a Starbucks $5 yeah you didn't
notice it's warm you didn't know you
were just counting them you didn't
notice that they were hydrants actually
look that one's a 100 that one's a 100
strong backing oh this is a trap this is
a trap this is a [ __ ] magician over
here you know what no wait I am a
magician yeah that's actually what I do
she brought in a [ __ ] magician guys
you're going to college to learn magic
tricks
I believe do you had glasses on and
everything pretend to be we're gonna get
to the real match if I bring this one up
on this side and this one up on this
side there's there's not three this is
actually just one long
Otis solid yes we line up the ends pull
down on the ball put your hand on there
believe that there - - I believe I
believe I believe I believe 14 oz dude
my new hobby is gonna be getting drunk
and going to magic ship I'm gonna draw a
B that's right there yeah do you know
how I get rid of sharpie you need like
rubbing alcohol or something you guys
might just be able to sweat sweat it out
there but if I squeeze tight just watch
watch don't move squeeze tight I drew in
my hand with sharpie right okay take a
look at my hands the X is on there Chris
take a look in your hand what the real
stories you passed out from drinking
[Music]
when did you put this here thank you you
guys you guys happy the internet we
happy versus agitated a couple jabs deep
and I look like a big ol magic is
[ __ ] real it's so cool believe in
magic because if Gary the doctor can put
an X on my hand which is still there
that's nothing play one of your balls
and you don't know that yet this is
crazy
didn't say it but I did on the check
[Music]